What did you write, David?
>> So I can tell that the first
thing the robot is going to have
to do to paint this ceiling
is climb the ladder.
So I'm first going to apply
the climb ladder operator,
that's going to result in
the robot being on the ladder, but
the state of the ladder and
the ceiling haven't changed.
And then now that the robot is on the
ladder, it'll apply the paint ceiling
operator, which results in painted
ceiling added to the state and
the dry ceiling negated.
>> That's good, David.
So this is the structure
of the final plan.
Another question to ask here is how
might a robot come up with such a plan?
So let's do the same thing that
we have done here earlier.
We're going to use goal as a control
knowledge to select an operator.
So we know that we want to
have the ceiling painted.
So the question then becomes
of the available operators,
which operator has a post
condition painted ceiling.
And the only operator who's
post-condition ceiling is the operator,
paint-celiling.
So we set up that operator.
So we're working backwards here.
Painted-ceiling was a good condition, we
selected paint-ceiling as the operator.
But this paint-ceiling now
has some pre conditions.
One of the pre conditions
is On Robot Ladder,
which is different from
On Robot Floor in the initial state.
So now the question becomes,
how can we achieve this sub
goal of Robot on Ladder?
If we use that sub goal as
the control knowledge, then we want
to select an operator whose post
conditions will match this top goal and
that operator is climb ladder.
So now we have that
climb ladder here and
the preconditions of climb ladder
match this initial state and
that is how we get to this plan,
climb ladder and paint ceiling.
So we were working backwards
using goal knowledge
as control knowledge to
select between operators.
>> So note that we just made
a connection back to problem
reduction that we talked about
right after means and analysis.
Ashok in his description talked about
the sub goal of getting up the ladder.
When we talked about
problem reduction earlier,
we talked about the need to break big
problems down into smaller problems.
But we didn't exactly talk about how
an agent would go about doing that.
Here we see one way in which an agent
would go about actually identifying
those subgoals in order to
accomplish the final goal.